there's nothing like a good 90s moment
to shove open those gates in Nostalgia
blue jeans flannel shirts MTV music
videos what's not to love well looking
back at a few Classic Movies there's
actually kind of a lot so sit back relax
and enjoy as we talk about some 90s
movies that definitely wouldn't have
gotten made today American Pie launched
the careers of some major actors of that
generation Alison Hannigan Tara Reid
Jason Biggs but there's a scene in it
that's well to say the least did not age
very well like Jason biggs's character
sets up a webcam in his room to secretly
record a girl getting undressed luckily
it does end up backfiring for him in a
hilarious way but still the scene's
origin is extremely harmful Jason talked
to BuzzFeed about how because of what
that scene represents it would not fly
with today's audience when he read the
script at the time though the only thing
he remembers being taken aback by was
that there were cameras on the computers
and considering I didn't even have a
computer in the 90s yeah that's pretty
understandable actually yeah all right
time to ruin the Academy Award winner of
1994. it literally beat Pulp Fiction and
Shawshank Redemption and considering Tom
Hanks won an Oscar for his performance
of a character depicted as slow-witted
Forest is right here would be taken a
bit differently nowadays his portrayal
of such a character would in today's age
be considered pretty offensive also like
his love interest to Jenny was written
as someone who lives a life of free love
but was given addictions AIDS and demise
it seems like at the time everything
that was ultimately wrong with this film
went over the audience's heads but today
well not all of it would fly honestly
when I first watched this movie it
definitely gave me the ick and I'm not
even gonna get into the fact that the
lead is played by Kevin Spacey and
regardless of Kevin Spacey or not the
movie is giving illegal if you haven't
seen it it's the story about a man in a
suburb who is going through a midlife
crisis and takes up an unhealthy
fascination with his teenage daughter's
friend he fantasizes about her in ways
that are just gross what's even worse is
the fact that the movie doesn't depict
it as gross at all it's viewed as a way
of him regaining his youth truth and
happiness to the point where he's framed
as some sort of hero Oscar goes to
American Beauty this movie won the
Academy Award for Best Picture in 1999
but today yeah there's no conceivable
way this story would have hit the box
office at all so this shouldn't come off
as too surprising the original film was
made in 1962 adapted from a novel but
then was recreated in 1997. why I
couldn't tell you I'm not gonna get too
into the nitty-gritty on this one but
this romance depicted between a much
older man who we are supposed to be
rooting for and an underage girl
crazy
yeah you get where I'm going I
definitely don't see a Lolita remake
happening in the 21st century so if
you've seen this movie you know where
I'm going with this one there's a
particular scene in it that would
definitely be considered a bit too
horrific today it's the dance scene the
one where Michael Madsen dances to the
song Stuck In The Middle With You as he
tortures a police officer tied to a
chair even in the 90s this scene had
fans walking out of the theater and the
reason it's considerably problematic is
because it's depicted as comedic instead
of horrific classic Drew Barrymore
what's not to love mostly just the
inappropriate student teacher
relationship big cringe Vibes there if
you haven't seen the movie Drew
Barrymore's character Josie poses as a
high school student to research the
culture of the students eventually Josie
and her English teacher Mr Coulson
developed feelings for each other even
though Josie's not actually underage Mr
Coulson doesn't know that and continues
making passes at her in ways that are
extremely inappropriate regardless he's
literally her teacher he shouldn't be
saying things like when you're my age
guys will be lined up around the block
for you like bro no that whole Ferris
wheel scene was just undeniably cringe
you have to say that because you're my
teacher no Josie no he shouldn't anyway
yeah this script would not pass the vibe
check in today's media shouldn't be
talking about this stuff with you I'm
sorry okay please do not come at me here
I still love Jim Carrey but a lot of the
jokes in this movie would never make the
cut in today's media I couldn't possibly
get into all the horrible ways trans
people have been depicted in the media
since the very beginning of the film but
basically that's what's happening here
in the film The Villain is revealed as
transgender God
is a man
the literal reveal happens when Ace
Ventura strips her down in front of the
police yeah problematic in itself there
was also the scene where after she
kisses him he pukes twice in the toilet
uses a whole tube of toothpaste to brush
his teeth Burns all his freaking clothes
and cries in the shower the scene in
itself is lewd distasteful and also
pokes fun at scenes and dramas where
women shower after being essayed a
classic Adam Sandler appears The
Waterboy was a major hit with 90s
audiences but over time since it has
been criticized for its use of offensive
language most notably the r word there
were also a ton of people upset by the
fact that the butt of the joke was a
bullied person with a disability and an
article on Vice States this issue
beautifully these movies imply that we
can make fun of minorities people with
disabilities the gays Etc all we want so
long as it comes with the increasingly
offhand message that there are people
too so this one particularly hurt not
gonna lie OG Sarah Michelle Geller fans
where are you at there are a lot of
things wrong with this movie but I guess
I shouldn't be too surprised given the
title this movie has been called out for
its portrayal of manipulation and victim
shaming screwing The New headmaster's
Daughter before school starts she'll be
my greatest Victory the main character
literally forces himself on Cecile
played by Selma Blair only to have it be
dismissed by Catherine who she thinks is
her friend the whole situation was
completely brushed over making Cecile
feel like the one in the wrong yikes
this was discussed in Miss magazine in
2019. Catherine uses the same technique
of victim blaming questioning people
often used when someone reveals they've
been essayed to convince Cecile that she
wasn't assaulted and that whatever
happened to her was actually her own
fault big big yikes Kevin Smith you good
bro this movie follows the story of a
man who falls in love with a woman who
he later learns is a lesbian after its
initial release the film received quite
a bit of praise but since then it's been
called out for its harmful depiction of
sexuality I love you I'm not not in a
friendly way this was covered in
BuzzFeed news back in 2017. ultimately
the film assumes that a lesbian can go
straight even if just for a little while
as soon as the right guy comes along
Kevin my guy a mellow dramatic speech in
the rain doesn't make someone not gay so
this thriller feature was making
headlines when both Madonna and Kim
Basinger dropped out of playing Helena
following up with a major lawsuit being
filed against Kim for backing out of her
contract from an outsider's perspective
it definitely seems like she did the
right thing like who is the target
audience for this movie during the trial
four jurors asked to be excused when
they found out the NC-17 film was going
to be shown in court one of the jurors
stated after being excused I don't care
what kind of movie stars they are I
don't want to sit through that movie The
Story of Boxing Helena is about a man
who is so obsessed with a woman he
amputates his limbs to keep her so like
if that sounds
undeniably problematic and cringe you'd
be right again please don't come for me
here Aladdin has been called out a lot
for its use of ethnic stereotypes like
all the bad guys have overdone Arabian
features where Aladdin is more or less
depicted physically as an American there
was also a song in the original cut
called Arabian Nights a lyric described
Agrabah as a place where they cut your
ear off if they don't like your face
like Disney faced a ton of backlash for
this and quickly changed it for the home
release version of the movie who else is
about to sift through their beloved 90s
movie collection with fresh eyes and
honestly sorry to do this to you even
with all the controversial films on this
list there are still tons of gems with
no inappropriate underage relationships
transphobia homophobia and offensive
language that we can look back on what
are some of your favorite non-offensive
90s movies
[Music]